You may have heard that Mercury is retrograde
again.
But if you try to find out what that means,
search results are dominated by astrologers
who believe Mercury can make you spill coffee
on your favorite shirt or cause your car to break down.
But if you set aside all those creative interpretations,
there’s actually a real astronomical phenomenon
underneath.
So let’s start with the basic layout of
our solar system.
The planets closest to the sun move faster
and the outer planets move slower, but they
all go in the same direction.
“Apparent retrograde motion” is when planets
appear to temporarily change the direction
of their orbit.
They don’t change direction, it just looks
that way from Earth.
It’s an illusion that unfolds over a matter
of weeks or months.
In this image, Mars was photographed every
5-7 days between October 2011 and July 2012.
Once all the photos were combined by aligning
the stars in the background, it appears as
though Mars looped back on itself before continuing
on its orbit.
A retrograde illusion happens when we lap
an outer planet, like we do with Mars every
2 years, or when an inner planet laps Earth,
like Mercury does every 4 months or so.
But for both Mercury and Venus, the illusion
is hard to actually capture since they’re
located on Earth’s day side, not our night
side.
When those planets are visible, it’s only right
around sunset and sunrise.
But assuming you could see it, here’s a
diagram of how the Mercury retrograde illusion
would work.
This line shows our view of Mercury against
the background stars.
As Mercury passes us by, our line of sight
shifts so that for about 3 weeks Mercury will
appear to loop back on itself when viewed
from Earth.
It’s simply a function of two objects orbiting
in the same direction at different speeds.
If you stood on Mercury, you would see Earth
make an apparent loop too.
I wanted to recreate this illusion on a tabletop
so I stuck a post-it note to the wall in the
background to represent the fixed stars.
I grabbed a ball of play-doh to be Mercury and my phone
camera is Earth. I took 10 photos of them
orbiting in the same direction with Mercury
passing by Earth.
If you simply view the images in sequence,
you don’t really see the loop, but remember,
the illusion is relative to the background
of fixed stars.
So once you line up the images so that that
post-it note star is fixed, the retrograde
loop appears.
Here’s another visualization of the retrograde
loop of Mars as Earth passes it.
The bottom part shows the positions of the
planets and the top is the corresponding view
of Mars from Earth.
The key is to always remember that Earth is
moving too.
So retrograde motion was baffling to early
astronomers who thought that Earth was stationary
and at the center of the solar system.
In the 2nd century, Ptolemy devised a complicated
system of loops and orbits within orbits to
account for the apparent retrograde motion
of planets.
That model was accepted for 1500 years because
it seemed to fit the observations, even though
it was completely wrong.
Once Copernicus showed that all the planets,
including Earth, move around the sun, then
then retrograde motion was easily explained as
an illusion.
So if there’s any life lessons to learn
from Mercury retrograde,
it’s that we may be vulnerable to illusions
when we think everything revolves around us.
It's really frustrating how misleading the scale is on every illustration of the solar system
So I feel compelled to point out that the real distance between Earth and Mercury,
when those planets are closest together, is more than 6,000 times the diameter of Earth.